Así que hoy quiero hablarles acerca del SIDA en el África sub-Sahariano
Éste es un público muy bien instruído,
así que imagino que todos ustedes saben algo acerca del SIDA.
Probablemente saben que cerca de 25 millones de personas en África
están infectadas con el virus, y que el SIDA es una enfermedad de la pobreza.
Y, que si logramos sacar a Africa de la pobreza, podriamos además disminuir el SIDA también.
Si saben un poco más, probablemente saben que Uganda, a la fecha,
es el único país en el África sub-Sahariano
que ha tenido éxito en el combate de la epidemia,
usando una campaña que motivaba a las personas a practicar la abstinencia, la fidelidad y a usar condones --
la campaña ABC por sus siglas en inglés. Ellos redujeron su prevalencia en los noventa
de cerca de 15% a 6% en tan solo unos pocos años.
Si les gusta la política, probablemente saben que hace algunos años
el presidente invirtió 15 mil millones de dolares para combatir la epidemia durante los próximos cinco años,
y mucho de ese dinero va a ser destinado a programas que van a seguir el ejemplo de Uganda
y utilizar el cambio de comportamiento para crear conciencia y reducir la epidemia.
Asi que hoy voy a hablar de algunas cosas
que tal vez no sepan acerca de ésta epidemia.
Y después, en realidad, voy a poner a prueba
algunas de esas cosas que ustedes creen que saben.
Y para hacer esto voy a hablar de mi investigación
de la epidemia como una economista.
Y realmente no voy a hablar mucho sobre Economía.
No voy a hablar acerca de exportaciones ni precios.
Pero si voy a usar herrmanientas e ideas que son familliares a los economistas
para pensar acerca un problema que es más tradicionalmente
un asunto de salud pública y epidemiología.
Y creo que en éste sentido, encaja bastante bien con la idea del pensamiento lateral.
Realmente voy a utilizar herramientas de una disciplina academica
para pensar acerca de los problemas de la otra.
Así que creemos, en primer lugar, que el SIDA es una cuestión de política.
Y probablemente para muchos de ustedes, así es como piensan al respecto.
Pero esta charla será para entender los hechos de esta epidemia.
Acerca de pensar como evoluciona, y como la gente responde a ello.
Creo que podría parecer que estoy ignorando las cuestiones políticas,
las cuales son las mas importantes,
sin embargo espero que al final de esta charla, puedan concluir
que no podemos desarrollar una política efectiva
a menos que entendamos como funciona la epidemia.
Y la primera cosa de la que quiero hablar,
la primer cosa que creo que debemos entender, es:
¿Cómo responde la gente ante la epidemia?
Así que el SIDA es una infección de transmisión sexual, y mata.
Esto significa que en un lugar con mucho SIDA
existe un importante costo de tener sexo.
Si ustedes fueran un hombre no infectado viviendo en Botswana, dónde la tasa de VIH es 30%
y tuvieran una pareja más este año - una pareja estable, novia, amante --
su probabilidad de muerte en 10 años se incrementaría en 3 puntos porcentuales.
Este es un efecto enorme.
Y creo que nuesto sentir es, que la gente debería tener menos relaciones sexuales.
De hecho entre la población de hombres gay de los Estados Unidos
sí encontramos este tipo de cambio durante los años ochentas.
Asi que si miramos este ejemplo de alto riesgo en particular, y les preguntaran:
¿Tuviste relaciones sexuales sin protección con más de una pareja en los últimos dos meses?
Durante el periodo entre el '84 y el '88, ese porcentaje cae de un 85% a un 55%.
Es un gran cambio, en un periodo muy corto de tiempo.
No vimos nada parecido en Africa.
Así que no contamos con datos muy precisos, pero como pueden ver aquí
el porcentaje de hombres solteros que tienen relaciones sexuales pre-matrimonales,
o el de hombres casados que tienen relaciones extra-maritales,
y su cambio desde principios a finales de los noventas,
y de ahi a principios de este siglo. La epidemia esta empeorando.
La gente esta aprendiendo más cosas acerca de esto...
La gente casi no ha cambiado su comportamiento sexual.
Hay solo algunas pequeñas reducciones -- dos puntos porcentuales -- no significativos.
Parece desconcertante, pero voy a decirles que no deberían sorprenderse ante ésto.
Y para entender ésto, necesitan pensar en la salud
de la forma en que un economista lo hace -- como una inversión.
Si usted es un programador de software y está tratando de pensar en
si debería agregar alguna nueva función a su programa,
es importante pensar acerca de cuanto costará ésto.
Tambien es importante pensar en cual es el beneficio de ésto.
Y una parte de ese beneficio es cuanto más tiempo
usted piensa que éste programa va a seguir activo.
Si la versión 10 sale la próxima semana,
no hay razón para añadir funciones nuevas a la versión 9.
Pero las decisiones en salud son similares.
Cada vez que usted come una zanahoria en lugar de una galleta,
cada vez que usted va al gimnasio en lugar de ir al cine,
esa es una inversión costosa en su salud.
Pero el cuanto va a invertir usted depende
en cuanto usted espera vivir en el futuro --
incluso si usted no realiza tales inversiones.
Con el SIDA es igual. Es costoso evitar el SIDA.
A la gente le encanta tener sexo.
Pero ustedes saben, tiene beneficios en terminos de longevidad.
Pero la esperanza de vida en África, incluso sin el SIDA, es muy, muy baja:
40 o 50 años en muchos lugares.
Creo que es posible, pensando con intuición, y pensando en los hechos,
que tal vez esto explica en parte tan bajo cambio en su comportamiento.
Pero realmente necesitamos probar eso.
Y una gran manera de probarlo es echar un vistazo a África y ver:
¿Las personas con mejores expectativas de vida cambian de mayor manera su comportamiento sexual?
Y la forma como voy a responder esto es,
echar un vistazo a áreas con diferentes niveles de malaria.
Ya que la malaria es una enfermedad mortal.
Es una enfermedad que mata a muchos adultos, además de muchos niños en África.
Y la gente que vive en áreas con muchos casos de malaria
van a tener una menor expectativa de vida que aquellas que viven en áreas con menos malaria.
Así que una manera de ver si es que podemos explicar
un poco de este cambio de comportamiento por diferencias en la expectativa de vida
es ver si existe mayores modificaciónes de comportamiento
en áreas donde hay menos malaria.
Y ésto es lo que nos muestra ésta figura.
Aquí se muestran -- en áreas con poca malaria, con mediana cantidad de malaria y mucha malaria --
lo que ocurre al número de parejas sexuales si incrementa la prevalencia de VIH.
Si miran la línea azul,
las áreas con bajos niveles de malaria, pueden ver en esas áreas,
realmente, el numero de parejas sexuales disminuye bastante
en tanto la prevalencia de VIH sube.
Áreas con un nivel medio de malaria disminuye un poco --
pero no reduce mucho. Y las áreas con altos niveles de malaria --
de hecho, se incrementa un poco, aunque no es significativo.
Esto no se limita sólo a la malaria.
Las mujeres jóvenes que viven en áreas con alta mortalidad durante el parto
cambian menos su comportamiento en respuesta al VIH
que aquellas mujeres que viven con baja tasa de mortalidad durante el parto.
Hay otro riesgo, y ellas responden menos a este riesgo existente.
Por si mismo, creo que esto les dirá mucho acerca de el comportamiento de la gente.
Nos dice algo acerca del porque vemos tan poco cambio conductual en África.
Pero también nos dice algo acerca de política.
Incluso si a ustedes les preocupe sólo el SIDA en África,
podría ser incluso una buena idea invertir en la malaria.
en combatir la pobre calidad de aire en el interior de los inmuebles,
mejorando la tasa de mortalidad durante el parto.
Ya que si mejoramos esas cosas,
entonces la gente va a tener un incentivo para evitar el SIDA por ellos mismos.
Pero también nos dice algo a cerca de uno de los hechos de los que hablamos antes.
Campañas de educación, similar a la que el presidente está centrando su financiamiento,
podrían no ser suficientes. Al menos no por sí solas.
Si la gente no cuenta con un incentivo para evitar el SIDA --
incluso si saben todo respecto de la enfermedad --
aún así podrian no cambiar su comportamiento.
Asi que la otra cosa que aprendemos aqui es que el SIDA no se va a terminar por sí solo.
La gente no está cambiando lo suficiente su comportamiento
para reducir el crecimiento de la epidemia.
Así que necesitamos pensar en la política
y qué tipo de políticas pueden ser efectivas.
Una gran manera de aprender a cerca de políticas es revisar lo que ha funcionado en el pasado.
La razón por la que sabemos que el programa ABC
fue efectivo en Uganda es que tenemos muy buenos datos a lo largo del tiempo.
En Uganda vemos que la prevalencia disminuyó.
Sabemos que tuvieron esta campaña. Así es como aprendemos de algo que funciona.
No es el único lugar en el que hemos visto intervenciones.
Otros lugares tambien lo han intentado, pero ¿porqué no volteamos hacia ellos
y vemos que le ocurrió a su prevalencia?
Desafortunadamente, existe muy poca información
acerca de la prevalencia de VIH en la población de África hasta cerca del 2003.
Así que si les preguntara: ¿Por qué no buscan por mí
la prevalencia en Burkina Faso en 1991?
Entran a Google, buscan -- y encuentran que,
en realidad, las únicas personas examinadas en Burkina Faso en 1991
son pacientes con enfermedades venéreas y mujeres embarazadas.
Lo cual no es un grupo muy representativo de la población.
Pero si indagan un poco más, descubrirán un poco más de lo que estaba pasando,
encontrarían que, en realidad, ése fue un muy buen año.
Ya que en algunos años, la única población examinada son adictos a drogas intravenosas.
Peor aún -- algunos años sólo a drogadictos,
en otros sólo a mujeres embarazadas.
No tenemos forma de saber que ha pasado a través del tiempo.
No tenemos pruebas consistentes.
Y en los últimos años, hemos llevado a cabo algunas buenas muestras.
En Kenia, en Zambia, y en muchos paises,
se han investigado muestras al azar de la población.
Pero ésto nos deja con una gran brecha en nuestro conocimiento.
Puedo decirles el indice de prevalecencia en Kenia en 2003,
pero no les puedo decir nada en 1993 o en 1983.
Siendo un problema de política, era un problema para mi investigación.
Y comencé a pensar como podría determinar
la prevalecencia de VIH en África en el pasado.
Y pienso que la respuesta es: podemos ver el indice de mortlidad,
y podemos usar el índice de mortalidad para darnos una idea de la prevalecencia en el pasado.
Para hacer esto, tenemos que confiar en el hecho
que el SIDA es una enfermedad muy específica.
Mata a personas en la etapa más productiva de sus vidas.
No muchas enfermedades tienen esa característica. Y como pueden ver:
ésta es una gráfica de indice de decesos por edad en Botswana y Egipto.
Botswana es un lugar con muchos casos de SIDA,
Egipto es un lugar sin muchos casos de SIDA.
Y verán que tienen indices de mortalidad muy similares entre niños y ancianos.
Esto sugiere que cuentan con con niveles similares de desarrollo.
Pero en el rango de edades entre 20 y 45,
el índice de mortalidad en Botswana son mucho, mucho más altas que en Egipto.
Pero debido a que existen muy pocas enfermedades mortales,
podemos atribuir tal mortalidad al VIH.
Pero ya que la gente que murió este año de SIDA lo contrajeron algunos años antes,
podemos utilizar estos datos de mortalidad para darnos una idea del indice de casos de VIH en el pasado.
Resulta, que si usamos esta técnica,
los estimados de prevalecencia son muy similares
a los que obtenemos de las muestras aleatorias de la población --
pero son muy, muy diferentes de lo que nos dice el grupo de la ONU en SIDA.
Ésta es una gráfica de prevalencia estimada por la ONU-SIDA
y la prevalecencia basada en los datos de mortalidad
en los últimos años de la década de los 90 en nueve países africanos.
Pueden ver casi sin excepción,
que las estimaciones de la ONU-SIDA son mucho más altas que las estimadas en el índice de mortalidad.
ONU-SIDA nos dice que el indice de VIH en Zambia es del 20%,
y los estimados de mortalidad sugieren que es sólo el 5%.
Éstas no son, saben, diferencias triviales en el índice de mortalidad.
Así que ésta es otra forma de ver ésto.
Pueden ver que para que la prevalecencia sea tan alta como la ONU - SIDA dice,
realmente tenemos que tener 60 muertes por cada 10,000
en vez de 20 muertes por cada 10,000 en este grupo de edad.
Voy a hablar un poco más en un momento
acerca de cómo podemos utilizar esta información para aprender algo
que nos va a ayudar a pensar acerca del mundo.
Pero ésto también nos dice que uno de los hechos
que mencioné al principio no podrían estar del todo correctos.
Si se ponen a pensar que 25 millones de personas estan infectadas,
y que los números de la ONU-SIDA son muy altos,
tal vez sean unos 10 o 15 millones.
No significa que el SIDA no sea un problema. Es un problema enorme.
Pero nos sugiere que ese número podría ser un poco alto.
Lo que quiero hacer, es utilizar esta nueva información
para tratar de de averiguar que es lo que hace a la epidemia de VIH crecer más rápido o más lento.
Y como dije al principio, sin hablar de exportaciones.
Cuando comencé a trabajar en éstos proyectos,
no estaba pensando realmente en datos económicos.
pero eventualmente me atrajo a éstos.
Así que voy a hablarles acerca de exportaciones y precios.
Y quiero hablarles acerca de la relación en la actividad económica,
volúmenes de exportación en particular, y las infecciones por VIH.
Obviamente, como economista, estoy familiarizada
con el hecho de que el desarrollo, que la apertura de los mercados
es realmente bueno para paises en desarrollo.
Es bueno para mejorar la vida de las personas.
Pero con la apertura y la inter-conectividad, existe un costo
cuando pensamos acerca de las enfermedades. No creo que ésto sea una sorpresa.
El miércoles, aprendí de Laurie Garrett
que definitivamente voy a enfermarme de gripe aviar,
y no debería de estar preocupada al respecto
si no tuvimos ningún contacto con Asia.
Y el VIH en realidad esta muy cercanamente ligado al transito.
La epidemia fue introducida a los E.U.A.
por un aero-mozo de un vuelo comercial,
quien se contagió en África y la trajo de vuelta.
Y esa fue el inicio de la toda la epidemia en los E.U.A.
En África, los epidemiólogos han notado por mucho tiempo
que los camioneros y migrantes tienen mayor tendencia a infectarse que otras personas.
Que áreas con mucha actividad económica --
con muchas carreteras, muy urbanizadas --
son aquellas con mayor prevalecencia que otras.
Pero esto no significa
que si impulsamos la exportación, el comercio, resulte en un incremento del índice de infectados.
Utilizando esta nueva información, usando esta información acerca de la prevalecencia a través del tiempo,
podemos analizar ésto. Y tal parece ser --
afortunadamente, creo -- parece ser el caso
que éstas variables están relacionadas positivamente.
Más exportaciones resulta en mas SIDA. Y el efecto es realmente enorme.
La información que tengo sugiere que si duplicamos el volumen de exportación,
conduciría a cuadruplicar los nuevos casos de infección por VIH.
Ésto tiene implicaciones importantes para las proyecciones a futuro, y para las políticas.
Pensando en proyecciones a futuro, si sabemos dónde es probable que cambie el comercio,
como por ejemplo, debido al Acta Africana de Crecimiento y Oportunidades,
o por otras políticas que promuevan el comercio,
podemos pensar cuales áreas van a ser más fuertemente afectadas con un aumento de casos de VIH.
Y podemos ir y tratar de tomar medidas preventivas anticipadas en dichas áreas.
De la misma forma, si desarrollamos políticas para promover la exportación,
si sabemos de esta exterioridad --
este factor extra que va a ocurrir si incrementamos las exportaciones --
podemos pensar en la clase correcta de políticas para esto.
Pero tambien nos dice algo acerca de esas cosas que damos por sabidas.
Incluso en el caso de que la pobreza esta ligada al SIDA,
en el sentido de que África es pobre y tiene muchos casos de SIDA,
no es necesariamente el caso que mejorando la pobreza - al menos no en el corto plazo --
que mejorando las exportaciones y el desarrollo,
no es necesariamente el caso que ésto nos conducirá a
reducir la prevalecencia del VIH.
Durante ésta charla he mencionado algunas veces
el caso especial de Uganda, y el hecho de que
es el único país en el África sub-Sahariano con un programa de prevención exitoso.
Ha sido muy elogiado.
Ha sido copiado en Kenia, en Tanzania, en Sudáfrica y en muchos otros lugares.
Pero también quiero cuestionar eso.
Ya que, es verdad que hubo una reducción en los casos
en Uganda en los 90's. Es verdad que tuvieron un programa de educación.
Pero hay algo más que ocurrió en Uganda en éste periodo.
Hubo una gran baja en los precios del café.
El café es el principal producto de exportación de Uganda.
Sus exportaciones cayeron bastante a principios de los 90's -- y de hecho
esta caída se correlaciona muy, muy de cerca a la reducción de los casos nuevos de VIH.
Como pueden ver éstas dos series --
la linea negra es el valor de exportación, y la roja son las nuevas infecciones por VIH --
Pueden ver que ambas están en aumento.
Cerca de 1987, ambas bajan bastante.
Y luego se comportan de manera similar
durante el incremento después en la década.
Así que si combinan la intuición y esta figura
con un poco de los datos que vimos anteriormente,
nos sugiere que en algún punto entre el 25% y el 50%
de la reducción de la prevalecencia en Uganda
podría haber ocurrido incluso sin llevar a cabo ninguna campaña de educación.
Ésto es muy importante para la política.
Estamos gastando mucho dinero en tratar de recrear esta campaña,
siendo que fue sólo 50% efectiva de lo que creíamos,
porque hay muchas otras clases de cosas
en las que tal vez deberiamos estar gastando nuestro dinero.
Tratando de cambiar las tasas de transmisión tratando otras enfermedades de transmisión sexual.
Tratando de cambiarlas promoviendo la circuncisión masculina.
Hay muchas otras cosas que deberíamos pensar en hacer.
Y tal vez ésto nos dice que deberiamos de preocuparnos un poco más en estas cosas.
Espero que en los últimos 16 minutos, les haya dicho algo que no sabían acerca del SIDA,
y espero que se hayan cuestionado un poco
acerca de loas cosas que sabían.
Y espero que tal vez los haya convencido
que es importante entender los hechos acerca de la epidemia,
para después pensar en políticas.
Pero más que nada, saben, soy una académica.
Y cuando salga de aquí, voy a regresar allá
a sentarme en mi pequeña oficina, ante mi computadora y mis datos --
y la cosa más emocionante de eso
es que cada vez que pienso en investigar, surgen más preguntas.
Hay más cosas que creo que quiero hacer.
Y lo que es realmente grandioso de estar aquí es
que las preguntas que ustedes tienen
son muy, muy diferentes a las que yo podría hacer.
Y no puedo esperar a escuchar cúales son.
Así que muchas gracias.